[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert König
für den Sport guten Abend schauen wir
auf die Themen von heute
erfolgreiche Schatzsuche ein Großteil
der geraubten Kostbarkeiten aus dem
Grünen Gewölbe in Dresden wurde
sichergestellt
Befreiungsschlag oder Umweltsünde die
Regierungsspitzen eröffnen Deutschlands
erstes lng-terminal kritiker warnen vor
neuen Gefahren für die Natur
und das kleine Finale ist Ehrensache mit
einem 2:1 werden die Kroaten WM Dritter
tun sich aber schwer gegen die
marokkanischen Atlas lösen
wir beginnen mit der Überraschung des
Tages ein Großteil der Juwelen von
Kurfürst August dem Starken ist zurück
in Dresden
spektakulär waren sie 2019 aus dem
Grünen Gewölbe gestohlen worden seit
einem Jahr läuft der Prozess gegen die
mutmaßlichen Täter doch die
einzigartigen Schmuckstücke Schienen für
immer verloren bis jetzt Stefan Kelch
hat mir
sächsische Geschichte gefasst den
Diamanten und Gold damals königlicher
prunkschmuck heute Schatz von Weltrang
geraubt vor drei Jahren jetzt
überraschend wieder aufgetaucht wie
wahrscheinlich ist es denn dass wir
diesen Schatz wiederfinden könnten und
wir haben uns immer betont optimistisch
gezeigt jetzt kann ich Ihnen sagen da
war natürlich ein bisschen Flunkerei mit
dabei natürlich je länger die
Ermittlungen dauerten schmolz auch
unsere Zuversicht und so freudige sie
mir dass wir heute hier stehen können
einiges fehlt doch 31 Einzelteile sein
jetzt sichergestellt worden darunter das
wohl wertvollste Stück der sogenannte
Große Bruststern des polnischen weißen
adleraugens die Hoffnung dass die
Kostbarkeiten nicht zerstört oder
einzeln verkauft wurden ist aber immer
da auch keine Hinweise darauf dass Teile
davon irgendwo schon aufgetaucht oder
verkauft waren auch in der Analyse
anderer kunststelle im Vergleich dazu
waren wir doch eigentlich sehr gewiss
dass es so eine Rückkehr kommen konnte
in einer unfassbaren Aktion zerstören
Einbrecher 2019 diese Vitrine im
Dresdner grün Gewölbe und rauben Schmuck
im Wert von 113 Millionen
4.300 Diamanten lassen sie mitgehen seit
Anfang des Jahres sitzen sechs
Tatverdächtige vor Gericht Mitglieder
einer arabischen Großfamilie nun hat
offenbar ein Deal zwischen Verteidigung
Gericht und Staatsanwaltschaft zum
Auffinden der Kostbarkeiten geführt
ein Deal mit den Angeklagten Cornelia
Siemens in Dresden was heißt das
also die Staatsanwaltschaft und die
Polizei haben sich ja gerade hier vor
den Kameras geäußert und das Wort Deal
hat natürlich keine in den in den Mund
genommen aber es wurde schon deutlich
dass der Fund in der vergangenen Nacht
alles andere als ein zufallswunsch war
es ist die Rede davon es gab
Sondierungsgespräche zwischen
Staatsanwaltschaft und den Verteidigern
der sechs Tatverdächtigen unter
Einbeziehung des Gerichts und in diesen
Sondierungsgesprächen soll es wohl darum
gegangen sein über eine mögliche
Rückführung von Beutestücken zu
diskutieren das ist nun offenbar
passiert weitere Einzelheiten wurden
erstmal mit Blick auf die noch laufenden
Gerichtsverhandlungen nicht genannt fest
steht aber jedenfalls dass die Freude in
Sachsen riesengroßes gerade zu
euphorisch weil es geht hier um den
Sachsen Schatz der ist nun mittlerweile
auch wieder in Dresden angekommen und
wird nun auf seine Echtheit hin
überprüft und sollte das wirklich alles
echt sein die Teile wirklich Teile des
gestohlenen Schmucks aus dem Grünen
Gewölbe sein dann ist das das größte
vorweihnachtliche Weihnachtsgeschenk was
man hier machen konnte und von dem
wirklich niemand mehr mit gerechnet hat
Dankeschön nach Dresden Cornelia
schiemens war das
großer Bahnhof heute in Wilhelmshaven
nicht nur der Bundeskanzler auch der
Vizekanzler und der Finanzminister
wollten das erste schwimmende
gasthterminal in Deutschland persönlich
einweihen diese Terminals sollen dazu
beitragen dass Deutschland unabhängig
von russischen Gas wird und jederzeit
genug Energie hat dazu gleich mehr
zuerst erklärt Petra Riffel wozu es
diese Terminals überhaupt braucht der
Weg von der Förderung beispielsweise in
den USA bis zur Einspeisung in das
deutsche Gasnetz ist lang das geförderte
Erdgas das hauptsächlich aus Methan
besteht mit extrem heruntergekühlt bei
minus 162
°c
verpackt in stark isolierten lng-tanks
kommt das verflüssigte Erdgas per Schiff
nach Deutschland am Zielort fließt es
ins spezielle Terminals auf dem Wasser
oder an Land hier wird das verflüssigte
Erdgas in verdampfungsanlagen wieder
umgewandelt von flüssig zu Gas um dann
ins Gasnetz eingespeist zu werden
in der Nordsee vor Wilhelmshaven ist
jetzt also das erste Terminal
einsatzbereit die Bundesregierung feiert
dass das so schnell ging Klimaschützer
dagegen werden es als Umweltsünde und
würden lieber den Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien Beschleunigen aus Wilhelmshaven
Fabian Köhler und Peter Kunz
links habe rechts Lindner in der Mitte
der Kanzler die Feldherren der
zeitenwände nach einem Jahr Ampel und
Krisen feiern sehen beißender Kälte
einen gemeinsamen Erfolg nach zehn
Monaten steht in Wilhelmshaven das erste
deutsche flüssig-erdgas Terminal welcome
Captain maskovic das von der
Bundesrepublik gechartete
regaifizierungsschiff Esperanza Hoffnung
soll Deutschland warm halten und von
russischen Pipelines unabhängiger machen
das ist jetzt das neue deutschlandtempo
mit dem wir Infrastruktur voranbringen
und es soll ein Vorbild sein nicht nur
für diese Anlage das Terminal in
Niedersachsen ist das erste von bis zu
11 an deutschen Küsten geplanten
Projekten die haben hier gebaut bevor
Sie eine Unterschrift von mir hatten das
Geld war noch nicht da und die haben
schon bestellt weil sie sich darauf
verlassen haben dass das schon kommen
wird
oder der Minister muss eben ein Hut
nehmen
kritiker fordern nicht den Kopf eines
grünen Ministers sehen grüne Ziele aber
beim neuen deutschlandtempo verraten wir
werden nicht akzeptieren dass es hier
umweltrabatte gibt wir wollen eine
Befristung der Genehmigung damit
Klimaziele eingehalten werden wir wollen
das auf den Einsatz von Biozid
verzichtet wird die Deutsche Umwelthilfe
will wegen chloreinleitungen der
Esperanza klagen während die
Bundesregierung den Wilhelmshaven Termin
auch für Gespräche rund um gasdeals
nutzte mit Botschaftern aus arabischen
Ländern an Bord Krieg Klima Energie
zeitenwände heißt derzeit Navigieren in
der Not und im Nebel nicht nur an der
Nordsee
in die Ukraine dort gab es auch heute im
ganzen Land Luftalarm erst gestern
hatten russische Raketen wieder zivile
Infrastruktur wie Kraftwerke getroffen
Moskau zeigte Bilder die den Abschuss
der Raketen von Kriegsschiffen
dokumentieren sollen
auch in der von Russland kontrollierten
Regionen um dann jetzt toben weiter
Kämpfe diese Bilder sollen die Schäden
an Privathäusern nach ukrainischem
Beschuss belegen
in Deutschland sind die Kinderkliniken
voll der Stress für Beschäftigte und
Patienten steigt und das hat teilweise
üble Folgen die Präsidentin des Roten
Kreuzes hasselfeld berichtet von
Drohungen und sogar von Übergriffen
gegenüber Pflegern und Ärzten die Eltern
zu informieren und einzubinden sei kaum
noch möglich sagte sie der Rheinischen
Post stattdessen müssen sie mit kranken
Kindern oft stundenlang warten
wer heute schon vor der Tür war hat's
hautnah erlebt es ist weiter klirrend
kalt vergangene Nacht saß so aus überall
Minusgrade oft zweistellig in der
Südhälfte südlich von Stuttgart sogar
minus 18 und kommende Nacht wird es auch
weiter nördlich und weiter südöstlich
frostiger gefährlich ist das besonders
für Obdachlose dieser Brücken hilft
zeigt Verena Gerrard
ein warmer Schlafplatz bei
Minustemperaturen früher konnten
Obdachlose in Saarbrücken im Kältebus
übernachten seit Corona ist das kein Bus
mehr sondern ein warmes Zelt mit 25
Schlaf Iglus 17 waren letzte Nacht
belegt die die herkommen bekommen etwas
was sie in ihrem Alltag nie haben Ruhe
Privatsphäre einen Rückzugsort sei er
noch so klein und alles Leute die
wirklich auf der Straße leben und hier
sagen wir mal warme Mahlzeit bekommen
und eine Möglichkeit im Warmen zu
schlafen und nicht
ausgeraubt überfallen oder sonstiges zu
werden von 9 Uhr abends bis 6 Uhr
morgens können sie sich aufwärmen manche
sind zum ersten Mal hier so wie Bartisch
er ist 34 vor acht Wochen hat sich seine
Freundin von ihm getrennt es ging ganz
schnell dann war er auf der Straße bis
vor zwei Monaten war ich als
Staplerfahrer und kommissioniere
ja dann hat sie mich auf die Straße und
wohne Wohnung keine Arbeit um Hilfe
bitten die Hemmschwelle ist oft hoch sie
wissen das hier und wollen es den
Menschen so leicht wie möglich machen
niemand stellt Fragen niemand wird
abgewiesen jeder hier hat eine
Geschichte die Ehrenamtlichen hören Sie
alle weit wegschieben kann man dann
eigentlich nicht weil viele erzählen
nach einer gewissen Zeit auch warum
weshalb sie auf der Straße sind und
viele Schicksale Bartisch will einen
Neuanfang er will eine neue Wohnung bis
er sie hat wird er nachts hier schlafen
es ist seinen Platz um kurz durchzuatmen
für die kalten Wochen im Winter
Tunesien ist das einzige Land das mit
einer Demokratie aus dem arabischen
Frühling hervorging jetzt rund zehn
Jahre später ist das Vertrauen ins
politische System kaum noch vorhanden
das zeigt auch die heutige
Parlamentswahl nur sehr wenige Menschen
stimmten ab zuvor hatte die Opposition
zum Boykott aufgerufen sie wirft
Präsident sei jetzt vor zunehmend
autokratisch zu regieren nach einer
umstrittenen Verfassungsreform wird das
neue Parlament deutlich weniger Macht
haben
morgen um diese Zeit wissen wir wer in
Katha Fußball-Weltmeister geworden ist
zum sportlichen Teil kommen wir gleich
vorher wollen wir noch einen Blick auf
die Bilanz dieser WM in der Wüste werfen
im Westen gab es anfangs viel Empörung
Forderungen nach Menschenrechten und
Diversität breiten auf die
Fußballbegeisterung Tausender Fans und
den Stolz auf die milliardenschwer
erkaufte Gastgeberrolle mit dem Fußball
bot die FIFA der Politik wieder eine
Bühne Kata 2022 was wird bleiben ein
Resümee von golini
marokkanisch panarabische Freude trotz
der Niederlage
Qatar 2022 steht für die herzerwärmende
Geschichte eines außenseites des fast
perfekte Ende der ersten WM auf
arabischem Boden
alle die negativ auf die Araber schauten
haben jetzt etwas Positives etwas
Schönes erlebt
offen gesagt hat die WM unsere
Erwartungen übertroffen wir Katara
hatten Angst vor Staus vor zu vielen
Menschen hier aber überall lief alles
sehr geschmeidig
ich muss sagen ich hatte eine tolle Zeit
hier die Organisation ist sehr sehr gut
gewesen aber alles war wie erwartet sehr
teuer
wo vor einigen Jahren nur Wüste war
strahlte und funkelte es zur Freude
vieler Fans
die Metro machte den Besuch gleich
mehrere Spieler am Tag möglich es kamen
weniger Besucher als Kata erwartet hatte
wohl unter einer Million sie nahmen hin
das Alkohol Haar war dafür aber die
Stimmung familienfreundlich und festlich
vor allem im alten wie du ihnen Markt
für sie änderte sich mit der WM nichts
die gastarbeiterkartes ohne die es keine
WM-Stadien und keine glänzenden Fassaden
gäbe
FIFA und Katar haben eigentlich eine
Chance vertan um die Menschenrechtslage
in
Qatar für cataris aber auch für die
Wanderarbeiter grundlegend zu verbessern
die FIFA sprach von der so wirklich
besten WM aller Zeiten und hob hervor
wie wichtig das Zusammentreffen der Fans
mit der arabischen Welt gewesen sein
das Fazit der FIFA ist das eine golinea
wir erleben Sie das Echo auf diese WM
ja für viele Deutsche Kritiker für viele
europäische Kritiker ist diese WM ja
schon vor Beginn gescheitert ganz anders
wurde das gesehen in vielen anderen
Teilen der Welt da hat Katha gepunktet
auch hier im Mittleren Osten nach einer
sehr schwierigen Zeit in der es hier in
der Region fast zu einem Krieg gekommen
wäre haben ehemalige geopolitische
Gegner langjährige geopolitische Gegner
das kleine Cutter besucht gelobt
wertgeschätzt die Botschaft die Kata an
die Welt senden wollte seht her wir
können eine perfekte WM organisieren und
auf Kritik aus dem Westen der reagieren
wir mit panoramaischer Solidarität also
ganz klar die WM hat das
Selbstbewusstsein der Golf Monarchien
hier insgesamt gestärkt die Devise
lautet nun hier Beziehungen zum Westen
ja aber nicht zu jedem Preis danke schön
für diese Einschätzung aus einem lauten
Dora
morgen Ende die WM mit dem Finale
Argentinien Frankreich aber jetzt
schauen wir erstmal auf heute und den
dritten und vierten Platz genau und den
dritten Platz den holt sich das Team aus
Kroatien nach
1998 zum zweiten Mal und damit bestätigt
der Finalist von 2018 erneut seinen Ruf
als starke Turniermannschaft die Auswahl
um den 37-Jährigen Luca Modric bezwingt
Marokko mit zwei zu eins
Luka Modric und sein möglicherweise
letzter WM-Auftritt eine ausgeglichene
und bis zum Ende spannende Partie 17
Minute Freistoß Kroatien Perisic auf
guardiol klassisch Standard der Kroaten
die Führung der Mann mit Gesichtsmaske
mit perfekten Kopfball
zwei Minuten später Freistoß Marokko der
Ball von Kroatiens maje zu darii der
Ausgleich Ashraf dari spekuliert und
profitiert gegen Ende der ersten Hälfte
nochmal Kroatien mit origić schöner
Schlenzer ins lange Eck misslaff orgic
mit dem 2:1 eine Viertelstunde vor
Schluss Marokko drückt auf den Ausgleich
Ende Siri livakowitsch pariert Kroatien
gewinnt und feiert mit Luca Modric Platz
3 in Katar das Überraschungsteam Marokko
trotz Niederlage einer der Gewinner
dieser WM
lange herrschte Funkstille nun hat sich
Bundestrainer Hansi Flick erstmals mit
Abstand ausführlich geäußert zum frühen
WM aus der deutschen Nationalmannschaft
er will den Fokus wieder mehr auf
Fußball lenken sportpolitische Themen
hätten sein Team zu sehr abgelenkt das
wm-haus ist noch nicht verdaut es hat
uns ja ziemlich hart getroffen und wir
sind auch wirklich auch Martin
enttäuscht gewesen wie wir alle anderen
auch ein Rücktritt den viele gefordert
haben kam für flieg nicht in Frage
nein weil mir einfach auch das Projekt
mit dieser Mannschaft am Herzen liegt
genauso wie beim ganzen Trainerteam
ersetzt große Hoffnungen in die neuen
Arbeitskreise die einen Bierhoff
Nachfolger suchen wir sind in sehr eng
Austausch und in sehr guten Austausch
und von daher
ich glaube sind wir auf da auf dem sehr
guten Weg will zudem zeitnah mit Thomas
Müller reden der seine Zukunft offen
gelassen hat doch das Wichtigste sei die
Fans wieder zurück zu gewinnen
das komplette Interview finden Sie in
unserer Mediathek und in der heute App
erster Saison Sieg für Vinzenz Geiger
der Olympiasieger in der Nordischen
Kombination gewinnt nach toller
Aufholjagd den weltcup-wettbewerb in
Ramsau am Dachstein zuletzt weil dreimal
Dritter geworden und im alpinen Ski
Weltcup hat Rennläuferin Kira weitle
Grund zur Freude die olympiavierte wird
drittschnellste bei der Abfahrt in St
Moritz eine halbe Sekunde hinter der
dominierenden speedfahrerin dieses
Winters Sophia Gotcha aus Italien es ist
der erste Podestplatz des Winters für
die alpinabteilung des DSV
und was ein blauer Himmel ja sehr schön
und morgen bei uns was anderes morgen
beschert uns der vierte Advent frostiges
aber ruhiges Winterwetter die Details
hat gleich Christa Augen viert das heute
journal mit Christian Sievers wir
wünschen Ihnen jetzt einen schönen Abend
und wenn Sie mögen bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend ein eisiges Wochenende ist
das teils mit zähmen Nebel teils aber
auch mit strahlendem Sonnenschein und
weißem Pulverschnee wie hier heute in
Rottweil ab Montag kommt dann aber der
Wetterwechsel mit Glatteis und einem
markanten Temperaturanstieg in Köln zum
Beispiel auf +10 Grad heute Nacht
erreichen wir ja teils nicht mal die
minus 10 Grad es ist klirrend kalt -4
Grad an der See und bei Aufklaren und
über Schnee minus 18 Grad dazu bildet
und verdichtet sich wieder Nebel der
sich morgen dann vor allem in der Mitte
und im Süden hält die Berge gucken da
aber raus und auch nördlich davon gibt
es viel Sonne also freundliches
Winterwetter am 4 Advent nachmittags
gibt es etwas mehr Wolken von Westen
hier dann auch Temperaturen bis plus 3
Grad ansonsten wieder frostig im
Dauernebel nur -8 Grad und in diese
frostigen Verhältnisse läuft dann in der
Nacht auf Montag von Westen her einen
Regengebiet wenn der Regen auf die
gefrorenen Böden fällt kann das höchst
gefährlich weil glatt werden im
berufsver von allem von vor allem vom
Saarland über das Rhein-Main-Gebiet bis
hinauf nach Hamburg und tagsüber breitet
sich der Regen mit Glatteisgefahr dann
auch Richtung Osten weiter aus ansonsten
geht die Woche wie gesagt deutlich
milder windiger und auch wechselhafter
weiter tschüss